US Attorney General Eric Holder arrives
in Ferguson today he's calling for an
end to violence we want to bring in
Bloomberg's Toulouse Oliver neathia
al-imran NEPA excuse me he's on the
ground and tolosa another night of
violence in Ferguson set the scene for
us here as Eric Holder enters the scene
what is the level of tension there well
last night there just a few hours ago
there was another round of violent
clashes it wasn't quite as violent as it
has been police did not use tear gas and
smoke bombs but they didn't line up in
their riot gear they arrested about 47
people and disperse the crowd using
using force Eric Holder's coming in
today and hopefully he's hoping to heal
the community and bring peace and do we
have any sense of who he'll be meeting
with when he'll be making public
statements we're not quite sure yet he's
been in close conversations with the
family that he is ordering up a separate
and independent autopsy of the body of
Michael Brown and that's one of the
things that he's going to be talking to
the family about to loose yesterday at
this time we were talking about 50 or so
people you described as instigators who
were rolling the crowd hundreds if not
thousands of others has that that
minority that faction quieted down
somewhat there are still those elements
we still see those elements in the crowd
a lot of them are taunting the police
officer some of them are throwing
bottles so they're still there I think
they have less than they had less
control last night than they did in
previous night's and police showed a
little bit more restraint and not using
the tear gas on everyone just to just to
apprehend those individuals Attila's
going back to the beginning of the
formation of the nation has always been
a federal and states rights issue over
our police forces let me be direct well
Attorney General Holder be greeted with
open arms in st. Louis in Ferguson and
for that matter within the state of
Missouri well at least in terms of that
rhetoric everyone has said they hope
that they're opening their arms to as
many investigations as needed they're
opening their arms to the federal
government to come in and look at what's
going on here so at least in terms of
the rhetoric that's that's the the
official statement we don't necessarily
know what's going on behind the scenes
and whether or not Eric Holder will be
completely welcomed as sort of a federal
federal power coming in to the state's
rights to lose every morning we wake up
and we hear about another night of
violence in Ferguson it starts off
fairly quiet things that turn violent
and confrontation happens what happens
during the day what happens in the hours
where there's daylight and things are
calm or presumably and we have things
like shopping centers that are now
police camp command post for the most
part things are very very calm and
peaceful during the day there is a
heightened police presence there police
on almost every block within the
downtown area of Ferguson but there's
not very much violent during the day
during the daytime hours the violent
elements usually come up at night and
that's why people have been encouraged
to only do they're protesting during the
day and to leave at night and I think
some of that have paid dividends last
night